kyle what was the best part about
coaching
in washington
um being able to work with my dad and be
around some other good coaches
that was the worst part
everything else
i and i liked a lot of the players some
good people
he had a little cleanup there at the end
didn't want to take a shot at the
players but man that was great that hey
that's great i like that i like that and
you know because number one we rarely
get that kind of candor because every
coach is so afraid of saying something
that's going to come back to haunt them
but really what kind of bulletin board
material is that going to give to
washington we're dysfunctional and we
know it i mean it's he's accurate and uh
yeah
and and who's gonna be mad about it
nobody in the locker room is gonna be
mad about this you're gonna be shaking
their head saying yeah he's he's he's
pretty much spot on with that
observation yeah i get it everything
does stink except for us players in the
locker room and some of the coaches uh
yeah i mean hey kyle has every right to
be bitter uh the shanahan family has
every right to be bitter i'm not gonna
get all the details of the things i know
from hearing from kyle and knowing a lot
of other people down there at the time
that were on the staff uh there was
dysfunction there was sabotage okay uh
more than once there was sabotage and i
think when you have that that's always
gonna piss off a two-time super bowl
winning head coach like mike shanahan
and then his son who was doing great
things on the offensive side and the
ball and kyle yeah of course this is his
dad you know it's almost worse when you
see your dad get mistreated than when
you get uh mistreated i mean i know
that's always the way i felt like with
my my own father's career you could talk
crap about me yeah chris sims you suck
at football blah blah blah great that's
great when we get into my dad i'm going
to get i'm going to get a little more
defensive and throw some crap right back
at you
well we played that sound bite because
that's the first topic for this week's
edition of what's more likely what's
more likely kyle shanahan and the 49ers
dropped 40 points on his old team in
washington or the 49ers believe their
own hype and get upset oh well this is
an easy one i mean if you're going to
make me choose between those i'm going
plus 40 points they might try to score
70 on the redskins i you know uh yeah i
just i don't think the 49ers uh the way
kyle is the way robert sala is they're
not satisfied i don't think they're that
type of team i think they're going to be
riding high on this like man we're
actually good for the first time in a
long long time here in san francisco
let's keep this going and dominate i
think there is a good chance they can
put up 40 on this redskins football team
yeah i'm with you i think it's going to
be uh uh
ugly and uh we we do our best bets every
week i already have a feeling you and i
are both going to be picking san
francisco
for that one
not not not nearly enough
uh i think it's yeah it's not nearly
enough so uh we'll be we'll be doing
that in the joint pftpm chris sims
unbutton podcast later today okay next
topic what's more likely the chiefs win
without a patron homes touchdown or
mahomes throws four touchdowns in a
losing effort oh man this is a good one
i think i'm gonna go with the first one
though the chiefs win without a mahomes
td
uh i don't see
the game being the type of game to where
the broncos got 35 or 40 points like
that and mahomes you know puts up 30 or
35 points and they lose as well and he's
got four touchdowns i think this is more
of a game that like we saw last year on
monday night where it could be 20-17 it
could be 23-20 that type of football
game and patrick mahomes doesn't throw a
touchdown pass
i'm with you on that if he throws four
touchdown passes they're winning the
game because the broncos aren't going to
be able to match that scoring output
right and for the for the broncos to win
and and here's the thing chris
i i here's where i'm torn will vic
fangio
in his first year as a coach at age 60
will he embrace the things that other
teams have done or will he say i'm going
to do it my way and and can he if he's
going to pivot to adapt the matt
patricia plan what the texans did what
the colts did what bill belichick did
man-to-man coverage if he's going to
change things up and change his
philosophy and do anything different
than what he's already doing can he do
it in three days
i do well i don't think he the good
thing with him mike is he doesn't have
to like reinvent the wheel on defense he
is good at all these things to begin
with he's always got some good creative
zones in the package and then yes
they're usually well taught when they
play man-to-man as well so i think
they'll be maybe not like detroit and
indy where they're just gonna say we're
gonna play man-to-man every play i'm
sure you'll see a good amount of that
but i do think there'll be some you know
deep zone packages as well where they
just keep everything underneath and call
kansas city's bluff that way uh and i
think they have the personnel in denver
too to make it that kind of game and
make this maybe ugly and and really make
kansas city work for a win
can they control the clock offensively
and keep patrick mahomes drinking
gatorade on the sidelines that's the big
question right that's what i'm not sure
about now we know this kansas city
defense is not good uh will kansas city
change its approach this week you know
will they will they listen to you know
the things i've been trying to say and
not that they're listening to me but
i do think they got to readjust their
approach they can't do this die slowly
defense i think they gotta like you know
you know crap or get off the pot here at
some point for lack of a better phrase
blitz cause havoc you either get a
turnover or they score a touchdown and
let's get the bat let's get mahomes back
on the field but i don't know if i'm
confident that denver can bleed the
clock out like some of these other teams
yeah i agree with you ben but don't
break doesn't work when you've got a
quarterback that you want back on the
field either because the other team
scored a touchdown or the other team
turned the ball over let's just get the
offense back on the field all right next
topic what's more likely earl thomas and
the ravens keep seattle under 20 points
or
russell wilson leads a fourth quarter
comeback to win the game this is a tight
one here i mean i would not be shocked
if this was a
17-14 kind of game i mean i don't think
it's totally crazy here but i think i'm
gonna go with the second option on this
one wilson leads a fourth quarter
comeback to win the game the ravens
defense is good um but the seahawks
offense continues to improve they can
run the football i think they have as
talented as a receiving core as they had
uh in the russell wilson era as far as
just four dangerous guys on the outside
and metcalf lockett uh jaron brown and
more they can all beat man-to-man
coverage and what concerns me with the
the ravens is they can't rush the passer
and they don't have great athletes up
front they got a lot of size and i think
russell wilson is going to be able to
run around and make plays and uh i think
they'll score more than 20 points and
here there's a good chance he does lead
them back in the fourth quarter to win a
game
yeah and really that that idea of earl
thomas who knows russell wilson was with
him practice after practice year after
year yeah the things that russell wilson
can do when the pocket collapses and he
squirts out if anybody has has a read on
how to deal with that and how to be in
the right spot where maybe there's going
to be a ball that's thrown that you can
get in position to grab or when he's
going to throw it where he's going to
throw it when he's out of the pocket
that earl thomas has inside information
like no one else in the nfl is going to
have all right last topic for what's
more likely what is more likely the
oakland raiders physically overpower the
green bay packers or the raiders offense
plays like it did the first two weeks of
the season when or the first three weeks
of the season uh when they did not
perform well yes another this is another
good one i i like these today these are
tough uh the one i think i would go with
the first one over the the over the
second one
i think the raiders offense has found
its mojo and found the formula that they
they like that fits their team and their
personnel and how john gruden wants to
coach he's doing an unbelievable job uh
really playing to his personnel about as
good as i've ever seen him do it and
they are going to run the football be
tough uh high percentage short passes
with the drop back pass game and he's
gonna take some play action shots that
you know he's gonna be the mad scientist
and come up with a few crazy plays to
try to screw over the secondary in green
bay so you know i would not be shocked
that this game ended up going back and
forth a little bit between the offenses
uh maybe not necessarily all big plays
on the raiders but them driving the ball
down the field aaron rodgers answering
back i could see this game being like a
31-28 type of game where the packers win
it
and if you're watching on tv there was
this shot of john gruden with the sneer
he had two weeks to get ready for this
when he's going back to green bay where
he was for three years before he became
the eagles offensive coordinator yeah
and he's going against one he's going
against the old gruden i've seen that
he's going against the guy he you've
seen it every day he's going against the
guy that gruden was 20 years ago the
young up-and-coming head coach i'm going
to show this punk who's who and i'm i
i bet i bet he slept even less the last
two weeks invigorated by the win in
london over the bears determined now to
get to four and two feels an opportunity
to turn this team into something and has
an opportunity to put everyone on notice
that the win at indy wasn't a fluke
right the win over the bears in london
wasn't a fluke you go into lambo and
beat the packers
everyone is on notice that the raiders
are back and i kind of like that it's
one of my favorite games of the weekend
i'm with you and the packers have shown
you know that the run defense is still a
question mark and no they got some big
nasty guys up front the oakland raiders
they're tough as hell uh and gruden to
your point he is that type of coach he
is he looks over the other sideline too
and he makes it personal to motivate
himself and you know come up with more
crazy plays and coach harder you know
i'm not going to get into names but you
know there was things he would say
through through my six years together
with him where yeah you know we were
playing a team and he he not only were
we worried about the matchup but i was
trying to motivate myself about the guys
that were across the line of scrimmage
he was motivating himself with the coach
on the other sideline as well
and think about this for the packers
devonta adams marquez valdez scantling
geronimo allison yeah jimmy graham right
none of them practiced yesterday all due
to injury it wasn't a veteran day off
for graham he's got an ankle injury that
we didn't know that we didn't know about
previously and aaron rodgers limited
again with a knee
this could get very interesting on
sunday for the raiders and the green bay
packers all right quick break when we
return the commissioner finally
acknowledges something that has been
floating around for weeks now the
possibility of a 17-game regular season
we'll talk about that more when pfc live
continues right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports